supporters of the defeated former
president have been demonstrating for
months picketing army bases around the
country demanding a military coup
against the new presidency of Lula de
Silva now they're being cleared out
riot police in the capital Brasilia
moved in breaking down their tents and
taking troublemakers away
what happened here appears not to have
been a random outpouring of anger
investigators believe it was actually an
organized attempted coup
that had been weeks in the making
and may have been supported by the
deposed President Joe bolsonaro who is
currently in Florida
on Sunday thousands of pro bolsonaro
supporters surged through the ramparts
of the institutions of the state
the Congress the Supreme Court and the
presidential Palace all fell to a mob
determined to take control of Brazil's
seat of power
crucially the security services were
either overwhelmed or did little to stop
them
their lack of action is also under
investigation
president Lula de Silva who wasn't in
Brasilia at the time has condemned the
uprising and he and his government are
promising punishment for everyone
involved
[Music]
those who attempted the coup terrorists
criminals in general didn't succeed in
their attempt to break the law we're
taking extra actions to maintain order
well they're doing their best to clear
up they're fixing the windows where they
can and the president is due back here
shortly
so the investigation into what happened
here is really going to focus on whether
this really was a concerted attempt at a
coup against the presidency of Brazil
and if that is the case then the
investigators will want to know who were
the conspirators
the investigation into what happened
here will doubtless look closely at the
events that took place in the United
States two years ago on Capitol Hill
the parallels between bolsonaro's and
Trump supporters their tactics and their
demands have been well documented
foreign
the supporters of these populist leaders
agree on many things
and never accepting that they actually
lost an election is one of them
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Brasilia